Петрові Порошенку не варто оманювати себе тим,
що нині на вулицях лише кілька десятків тисяч протестувальників,
радить українському президентові Міхеіл Саакашвілі.
Бо вони дуже швидко можуть перетворитися на мільйони,
переконаний лідер "Руху нових сил".
Головна проблема Порошенка - він узурпував владу.
З президента він вирвався в абсолютного монарха в Україні ХХІ століття,
е історично ніколи не було абсолютних монархів.
Це настільки все абсурдно.
І чим більше він намагатиметься встановлювати це, тим швидше лусне вся його система,
яка виглядає, з одного боку, дуже нахабною, а з іншого - дуже слабкою.
Головну слабкість Порошенка Саакашвілі вбачає в свавіллі української влади.
Мовляв, українці терплячі, але лише до пори - до часу.
Водночас лідер "Руху нових сил",
що регулярно закликає людей на мітинги в центрі Києва,
вважає, що нового Майдану не буде.
Каже: переможемо спокійною народною силою.
Її боїться не лише Порошенко, але й Володимир Путін,
вважає український опозиціонер.
Саме через це російський президент порівняв Олексія Навального з Саакашвілі
на своїй щорічній прес-конференції.
Лідер "Руху нових сил"  посянює приниження обох опозиціонерів
страхом Путіна втратити тотальний контроль в Росії.
У Путіна є чіткі асоціації.
Він собі уявляє, що от він вкотре саджає Навального,
а потім приходить великий натовп в центрі Москви молодих симпатичних людей,
голими руками нападають на його спецпризначенців,
забирають звідти Навального і везуть його прямо в Кремль на руках виносять.
І це для нього повна істерика, що ось в якийсь момент
поліція не чинитиме спротив, а людей буде так багато,
що вони просто зметуть його.
У даному випадку Путін виявився солідарним з Порошенком, додає Саакашвілі.
І не тому, що він симпатизує українському президенту.
Просто Путін поставив себе на його місце
і вважає таку ситуацію для себе дуже небезпечною.